hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on robust
reproducible protein quantification in
plasma using evosep 1 and agilent 6495
lctq by lin
linfing wu
i am abby pell of lab roots and i will
be moderating today's event before we
begin i would like to encourage you to
engage with us you can submit as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation
simply type the question into the ask a
question box on the left side of your
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right or use the
ask a question box on the left
it is my honor to please welcome len
fingwoo
thank you everyone
my name is lin von woo
today i'm going to present our work for
peptide quant in plasma using a new low
flow lc system called evoc 1 coupled to
agilent 6495 triple quadruple lcms with
agilent nanospray source
first i would like to talk about
targeted protein quantification in
translational research
nowadays a trend in translational
research is to study mater omics such as
genomics epigenomics transcriptome
proteome
metabolone lipidum and their
relationship with environment and they
study their interaction with each other
so the expression of this material mix
result in phenotype
today my presentation is focused on
proteomics
in biomarker evaluation and precision
medicine
you users
often need to target a limited number of
protein biomarkers and then monitor the
expression change during a period time
so this type of study often ends up with
several hundred to even thousands of
biological samples
this will require a
analytical technology which can
be very reproducible and very robust
multiplexing liquid chromatography
mass spectrometry is a very powerful
technology
it has been widely used for targeted
for targeted protein quantification
to achieve best uh robustness and
reproducibility
standard flow lc triple core is a
it is a platform which preferred
compared to
nanoflow and
microflora lcs ms system
here on the left is a picture of agilent
6495 lc triple core
coupled with a 1290 infinity to lc and
the jet stream source
so this is a standard for lc triple core
it has a
superior analytic code sensitivity and a
very robust and reproducible so it has
been well accepted by the market for
targeted peptide quantification
here on the right
is the example of mri chromatogram
from 99 targeted peptide using this
platform
so so this in this uh myochromatogram
the peptide retention time has a wide
varied uh very differently and the amine
chromatogram
uh varied uh in a wide dynamic range
in terms of peak width a medium full
width at half maxima is only 3.5 seconds
from these 99 peptides
so you can see this lc platform can
generate excellent
peak separation
so using this platform agilent has
generated a bunch of application nodes
so it can be
downloaded from agilent website
using standard floor lcms system
users often need to load a more sample
on the column to achieve optimal
analytical sensitivity but sometimes
users are sample limited
so in this scenario a low flow lcms
system is often
preferred
this is why we
evaluate a new low microphone lc system
evo cell 1 and coupled to agilent 6495
lc triple core to supplement the
this scenario for people who are sample
limited
so in this lc setup we have evil step 1
lc
coupled to agilent nanospray source and
agilent 6495 lc triple core and all the
data showed here in this presentation
has been using this lcms setup
here on the bottom shows the screen
capture of the nano spray
monitored by the camera
on this system and in the middle is the
picture of the clamshell which it can
hold in a little collar and
spray emitter um here the analytical
collar and the
spray
emitter are provided by the evo step
company
and the spray emitter is a stainless
steel
emitter and this this uh can this
result in very robust sprayed in our
test
and this collar and the emitter fit
nicely into agilent clamshell and
which are going to the of the nano spray
source
evosep1 is a standardized platform which
was mainly designed for
robustness and high superstatic
achieved this by using a disposable trap
column
sample was first
loaded and desorted offline on a paper
tip called the evo chip
then the other sampler will pick up the
evil tip place it in place it in the
injection pole
evoc one has four low pressure pump and
a one high
four low pressure pump and one high
pressure pump
the using a gradient of side focusing
technology to deliver llc separation
so first the two low pressure pump will
deliver a gradient with a reality steep
steep slope gradient which is uh
which shows as a red line in this
gradient plot
and they they the sample after the
sample you looted the phone
from the evil tip the other two
pressure part will deliver another
uh
gradient which will which is really
gentle gradient and it will offside
offset the first gradient and may
approve from the gradient in the storage
loop
then the high pressure pump will push
this preform gradient in the storage
loop onto the analytical column
so this integrating the illusion uh can
reduce the uh
and can reduce the um
the injection cycle of a head
and they will remain the
they will be they will remain the
contaminant on the uh evil tip cartridge
which will be disposed after each
injection
uh since all the um illusion and
gradient formation happened at low
pressure so they can minimize the
minimize the wear and minimize wear and
tear
evoc provides
six methods
which cover a range of user cases
from high support studies such as 300
samples per day
to
to proteomics discovery type
study which will give a 15 inject 15
injection per day so the lc flow rate
can range from 4 microliter per minute
to 220 nanoliter per minute
using this system we design
we design experiments to evaluate their
performance
here is our experiment flow to evaluate
this platform we first took human plasma
and diluted with ammonium bicarbonate
after dilution we denature reduce and
alkylate the sample then trypsinize the
sample
after trypsin addiction we lythalized
the samples
and then we took a stable isotope
labeled a standard peptide mixture from
a biomarker assessment kit which was
purchased from mri proteomics
we rehydrate this excise peptide mixture
spiky into a
plasma digest
we prepare two sets of sample for
evaluation the first set sample is
is for standard curve analysis we spike
the sample at eight different
concentrations we replicate
and the second set of sample is a large
stock of uh plasma digest
with sis peptide at 10 phantom mole per
microgram
and we
with many replicates so for robotics in
this test we
injected a continuously injected
replicate sample
replicated samples and to test the
signal stability
we performed the three experiment in
this performance first we
first we load all the sample onto evil
tip before robustness test
and we inject the standard occur samples
with replicates which end up the way a
concentration each concentration have
five replicates
and then we
on the same column we inject the robust
we perform the robustness test
using the same
uh sample and after robustness tests we
enjoy the remaining standard course some
proposed to
create a identical uh
identical standard code which
which
similar as the experiment one
behold before i show the
result i would like to highlight a few
things about the lc ms method used in
this work
so in these
three experiments we monitored uh 33
pairs of heavy and light peptides which
totally gave us
which totally has 198
mm transition so we use an analytical
column
which provided by evo sap the colon is
870 meter
long and
100 microgram id
and the four ray will use one microliter
per minute the lc gradient lens is 21
minutes including the injection and the
post gradient washing it's the cycle
times 24 minutes
so this will allow us to inject 60
samples per day
including sample method development and
performing all the three experiments we
continually operate the system almost 12
days this gave us a total of 654
sample inject
six sample injections
for each injection we load about one
microgram plasma digestion column now
during this
test we didn't change the column all the
experiments were performed on the same
column
and we didn't change the
spray emitter and didn't adjust the
spray voltage so and also we didn't
hume or clean the mesh by system
for convenience i first i'd like to show
the robustness test results
in this tester
we we perform totally of
574
replicates and monitor 33 pairs of
peptides so here shows the retention
time distribution for all targeted
peptides
the different peptides were coated in
different colors
so from this product you can see the
retention time
quite stable throughout this test
that means the analytical column back
pressure was now increased
during this stress test
and there's only a little bit bump in
the middle so the the retention time um
cv
uh for for all these pep pads it's a
range from 0.4 percent to 2.7
and most peptide has a series below 2
percent
next i will look at the peak area
from the relative standard deviation
histogram you can see a median of isd a
media iso 8.5 was achieved which was
represented by the blue dashed line here
and 94 percent of peptide has
isd below 16
which was represented by a red dashed
line here
there's only two pairs of peptide
has really high
icd
and we examine these two pairs of
peptide one
one pair peptides are degraded fast
it's they are not very stable because we
observe more than 50 percent
degradation after
overnight incubation at 4 degree
the other pairs of peptides we observe
very severe
background interference so we have to
manually integrate the peptide which
causes a lot of variation
so from this result we conclude that
these two outer layers
are not due to platform variation
and
here shows the mi peak area distribution
from four selected peptides and these
four peptides are represented by
different color and each dot means one
replica injection
and
overall you can see the mi peak area is
quite stable
and
these four peptides the the highest
response peptide has about 11 volts
signal response compared to the lowest
response peptide and this stable
isotope labeled peptide are mixed at
equal amount so
you can see
um
from the
bottom three peptides their signal
response has about one fold difference
from each other
and from these four
peptides you can see the the peak area i
see range from six percent to seven
point nine percent
and their retention time isd range from
point
five point five nine percent to one
point zero four percent and they are
quite uh stable if you consider this is
running at one microliter per minute
and next i would like to show the
standard curve analysis which performed
right before and after the robustness
test
and for both standard curve we prepare
the sample at the same time
and they all have a concentration and
each week each standard code we inject 5
replicates for each concentration so we
try to generate identical the standard
curve before and after robustness test
here shows the two standard curves from
the same peptide which match to
complement c3
from this two standard curve you can see
they looks very similar
and both have r square close to 0.999
percent
and external uh
concentration ranging from four atom to
100 phantom on column in plasma matrix
when you zoom into the bottom
uh
low concentration area you can see both
uh standard curve achieve a lower limit
of quantification at 10 atmos column
so here we define lower limit of
quantification by using a criteria of um
isd lower than 15
and the accuracy
between 80 to 120 percent
we next look closely on the data quality
from these two standard curves
here on the left shows the min
chromatogram from the low levels
using this two standard curve
so here shows the
m ion chromatogram from matrix blank for
add more on column 10 add more on color
and 20 atoms on column
you can see even at this low levels
this platform can create clear detect
chromatogram peaks
on the right is the table calculating
the
precision and accuracy using this two
standard curve
you can see at the
lower limit of quantification level
level which is 10 atmos column
uh this
platform can achieve about 10 percent
isd
and the quantification accuracy is
between 20 to 120
and at all the tested levels we can
achieve a pretty good
precision and accuracy
all the data showed in this presentation
has been published as an application
note if you are interested on the
details you can download this
application note from agilent app
website
with all this data we concluded that
using this evocap1 coupler to action 64
95 lc triple core we can achieve very
reproducible lc retention line for high
throughput study
and the mi signal response showed
a very very stable signal throughout
almost a 12 days operation without any
adjustment on lcms system and we can
achieve a similar standard curve for the
same peptides before and after
robustness test on the same single
column
since we upload all the
samples on the evo tips before
robustness test and then we store the
tip
in a 40 degree refrigerator
we didn't see obvious sample degradation
during this process
so we can conclude that the sample
storage on the evo tips are quite stable
in the end i would like to thank our
colleagues at agilent technology and our
collaborator from evosep especially
nikolai badger
he helped us
doing this
testing experiment and also deliver a
training
at agilent site thank you very much
with that i'm ready to answer your
question
thank you linving for the very
informative presentation
and at this time we will continue with
our q a
portion of the presentation
just as a reminder you can submit a
question to the ask a question box
all right we have a few questions
um that are coming in
and i want to first ask you olympian
uh the first question is are the lc
software and ms acquisition software
integrated together
and since then
er sorry
go ahead
and the second portion of that question
is since the lc and ms instruments are
from two companies how many computer do
you need to control the lcms mc platform
okay so the lc and ms acquisition
software are now integrated
integrated together they are standalone
software but you only need one computer
so these two software installed in the
same computer
and then the sample work list was
entered in the software called chronos
and from this
software you can enter your sample
information and select the lc and ms
messer
respectively and the two instrument will
connect it through a remote cable
great thank you so much limping
and our second question is uh can't
users create their own lc methods using
evosap
currently the answer is no so right now
evosep provides six lc methods which
cover the different user scenarios uh
from high super study for example like
300 sample per day to discovery type
study to where with 15 samples per day
so the flow rate range from 220
nanoliter per minute to four microliter
per minute but the user cannot customize
the mess right now by themselves
great thank you so much
and i think we have a little bit more
time here for
a couple more questions
our third question is after loading
samples on evo tips will the tips dry
out
this is a good question so after sample
loading i added some solvent a in the
tip box
so that the the top of the tip was
soaked in solvent a and this can prevent
evil tips from drying out during your
sample your long-term storage and also
during
the
data
acquisition great and
okay and i believe john here has a
comment um
yeah i'd like to just offer a quick
comment if i could and that is that uh
agilent has a agreement now with the
evil stuff it's a co-marketing
arrangement with evosep and just two
quick comments on what drove this we
really see evosep as helping to solve
some of the very sample limited
applications with robustness of goodness
um the issue in
nano and and 0.1 millimeter columns
uh two big issues that they've solved
one is uh when you get a let's say a 96
well plate and you had one bad sample it
oftentimes would then cause
contamination throughout the entire
system such that
if you had one bad sample on most
conventional nano systems
you'd be down cleaning flushing for days
and days with evocef having a cartridge
for each sample
if you get one bad sample you're
primarily contamination is oriented in
that one sample
so that's one nice problem they solve
they also really help with transfer of
methods their ability to transfer
methods
is greatly enhanced over other
traditional nano systems so we'll have a
lot more to come on this as we go
forward but we're very excited with the
relationship with evosep and the
co-marketing agreement and lynn fang's
been a big part of helping us get this
all going
thank you so much john
for that wonderful information
um
if we have no more questions today we
will be um just ending the presentation
and wrapping up a little bit early today
but as a reminder to our audience
questions we did not have time for today
um and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
and just want to thank you again to
limping woo for your your presentation
and your research
and to everyone who participated in this
presentation we hope you enjoy the rest
of today's event